so our daily cancellation today on a
Friday is uh all about a dispute at a
drive-thru Lane and needless to say this
is a deeply important issue and it's one
that has evoked strong feelings from the
public uh there's a lot to say about
this random video of two people arguing
in a drive-through Lane and yet still
most people seem to be missing some of
the uh nuances and complexities of this
issue so we'll go through them today as
New York Post reports this week a video
has gone viral of a mom at a Panera
breed drive-thru trying to order her
meal
while the Panera Bread employee on the
other end refuses to take the order
because the woman's daughter is
allegedly screaming and I should tell
you that perhaps as you'd already expect
um thousands of people have reacted to
this clip and the peanut gallery's
verdict is almost unanimously on the P
Panera Bread employees side so everybody
agrees that the customer who some have
dubbed Panera Bread Karen is in the
wrong here and let's uh watch the video
and see if the internet got this one
right which of course they didn't but
let's watch it so you are going to
refuse to take my order because my child
was screaming yes I have the right to do
that if you're more than welcome to
comment side or you can place an order
online and we'll make it for you and
what is really like you're going to not
take my order yes ma'am that is what I'm
saying okay all right well I do have
this on video and I will be emailing
corporate because that's just like
completely rude I can not come inside
because my daughter does not have shoes
on do you understand that no man I
understand but you're also more than
welcome to order through uh online as
well so you want me to take an extra 20
minutes in order
online that's not convenient to me it's
your job to take orders and stuff and
this is
ridiculous so I'd like you to take my
order
please okay I will be happy to take your
order as long as stream all
right I think that's a pretty good
decision on your part okay I don't need
this attitude okay now let's walk
through this uh three points of
analysis first of all we can't even talk
about the dispute until we deal with the
fact that this woman went to a Panera
breed drive-thru in the first place like
there is simply no good reason there's
no valid excuse to ever go to a Panera
breed drive-thru Panera sells High
school cafeteria caliber food at sitdown
restaurant pice prices I mean it's the
worst of all worlds you get the prices
of a sitdown restaurant place with sub
fast food
quality uh meals the sandwiches are
bland the baked goods are stale and
depressing the soups are Campbell's tier
at best I mean they taste like something
that was in a can that's been sitting in
your pantry the salads are salads so
it's a disaster all around uh and paner
is awful for every meal but I think
breakfast is the worst Panera breakfast
tastes like the continental breakfast
that you would get at like the comfort
in down the street um except that the
comfort in the breakfast is
complimentary at least and also the
comfort in coffee would be far better
than what they serve at Panera Panera
coffee is an Abomination that cries out
to God for vengeance um if I served you
and I think this is true if I served you
Panera coffee and I didn't tell you it
was coffee you wouldn't know what it was
supposed to be you would be flumix you
would you would have no idea what you're
ingesting it's this lukewarm dull weak
uninspired sort of vaguely caffeinated
liquid substance and again Panera
commits all of these culinary sins while
charging premium prices for them so
that's what makes it so bad so paner is
terrible that's the first thing you
shouldn't be there
second uh with that
established we we move to um the
employee now as mentioned uh most people
are on his side and uh that's no
surprise given that most people are
stupid and now the woman is not
blameless here which I'll explain in a
moment but neither is the employee okay
we can't know for sure what was
happening before the video began uh we
can't know how much screaming the child
was doing but I think it's fair to
assume that it was on par with what we
heard in the video and and yes we can
hear a couple of outbursts from the
child uh in the background and children
do that sometimes they're known to do
that but it's nowhere
near a level of noise that would make it
impossible to take the woman's order
like it's a little Annoying and slightly
distracting but you can still do your
job you can still do the thing you're
paid to do the only the only thing
you're paid to do is to is to stand
there and take the orders of the
customers and and the idea that you
could have someone say well this I don't
I'd rather not I'd rather not with you
you you displease me you displease ex me
please please continue on I'm I'm
displeased I won't take your order and
the fact that everyone's on this guy's
side are you kidding me even if the
screaming was a little worse before
before the video started that's also
possible still it seems unlikely that
the drive-thru worker was literally
unable to complete the order all signs
point to the fact that the paner
employee simply found the child's
whining irritating and so he decided
that he wasn't going to do his
job and he says I have the right to not
take your order no you don't don't Bud
actually you don't have the right it's
Panera Bread decides you work for them
they decide and I'm pretty sure Panera's
Bread does Panera Bread have a policy
that you don't have to take an order if
there's a child crying in the background
is that their policy really I'm pretty
sure it's not so no you don't have the
right do your freaking
job uh that's just not how it works or
at least not how it should work but
increasingly it does work this way
because the sense of entitlement in this
country is out of control and it's
particularly glaring in the service
industry where and you know nobody wants
to call this out or talk about it cuz
like you sound atist or something but
but we all know it you go into these
places the workers are visibly and
audibly angry that you're that just
they're already angry that you showed up
in the first place to make them do their
job and uh everyone Demands a tip for
everything no matter how shoddy the
performance is and employees think
nothing of openly complaining about and
about their customers and lecturing them
sometimes uh you know on social media
and so I see this incident as part of
that whole picture
now more old school as you know I have a
traditional mentality about these things
which which which is to say I have the
right mentality about these things and
my mentality is this do your damn job
just do your job uh yeah it's difficult
the kids crying I don't care do your job
anyway it's still your job just do it
you're annoyed you're sad you're upset
your tummy hurts I don't care do your
job I say this is a general principle it
applies to everybody all Industries we
have reached a crisis level of people
not simply doing their damned jobs
you know but this is is how I was raised
in fact I can remember when I first
started working as a teenager and uh and
I would work these kind of service jobs
and I did a lot of them and I would come
home after my shift and I'd complain to
my parents about about all the annoying
customers and the you know incompetent
managers and uh how unhappy I was in my
job and I don't want to go and my dad
would look at me and say like do you
think the point of your job is to make
you happy is that do you think that's
why you're there no the point of your
job is to fulfill your responsibilities
to do what your boss asks you to do and
to earn a paycheck so it doesn't matter
whether it makes you happy or not that's
what you're supposed to do the news for
you there millions of people go to work
every day and they're not happy doing
what they do but they do it anyway
because it's their
responsibility but you know this is what
I would hear growing
up um it's glaringly apparent that many
people today do not have dads at home
who will give speeches like
that so instead we end up in exactly the
situation we find ourselves in you know
like that guy that I don't know who that
guy was in like sounded like a younger
guy sounded like probably a teenager or
something um I would hope that if he's
got a dad at home like if that was my
son and I heard that video that that
kid's going to have problems when he
gets home with me okay because I want to
say first of all do your job second of
all don't that's don't don't speak that
disrespectfully to someone don't this
this woman do not disrespect her that
way uh telling her to adjust her
attitude who the hell do you think you
are like this is the kind of thing the
kind of message
that kids need to hear and they
don't um third with all that
said I still cannot take This Woman's
side uh my contrarianism can only take
me so far on this one now yes I think
she's right to expect that her order
should be taken yes I understand why she
doesn't want to go in in order because
her kid doesn't have shoes and and I
know there are some people online who
were say why do your kid why does your
kid have shoes you know cuz if you're a
non-parent you might might be judgmental
about that but parents understand that
sometimes you need to leave the house
your kid has lost her shoes for the 97th
time this week and you got to go and
you're not going to be going inside
anywhere anyway you're like forget it
never mind you don't need your shoes
we've all been there so um so I'm with
this woman every shoeless step of the
way except for one point she recorded
and posted it you know not every minor
dispute with a stranger needs to become
content for public consumption it is
possible Believe it or or not to Simply
have a disagreement with another
person one where they are
wrong and have a contentious back and
forth and then it ends and you move on
with your your life and that's
it like it's possible to do that and
before the internet that's what everyone
did all the time can you believe it
people would have you get into conflicts
you get into arguments you would get you
know someone would wrong you in some
small way and and and it it it just
happens and you experienced it and it
kind of sucked and then you kept kept
living and that was it and it was it was
over uh not everything needs to live
forever on the internet not everything
needs to be discussed not everything
needs to be content um and recording it
and posting it it's like the adult
version of being a tattletail you know
oh yeah I'm telling Tik tock on you so
the moment you do that you automatically
become the bad guy or at least one of
the bad guys so in this case as far as I
can tell they're both bad guys the
employee is wrong for not taking the
order the woman is wrong for recording
it and snitching to the internet uh the
internet is wrong for siding with the
employe Panera Bread sucks everyone is
wrong everything is bad everyone
involved is
cancelled happy Friday if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed